[Musica]
bene io sono molto contento di essere
qui perché sono nato e cresciuto a san
severo
molti dei miei affetti sono sono ancora
lì e sono legatissimo in queste terre
oggi vi parlo del sears la beals slave
un laboratorio presso l'università dove
sono professore di robotica e questa
storia nasce da nasce da qui perché io
ho studiato a san severo poi mi sono
mosso verso l'università e da lì ho
cominciato la mia carriera accademica
ricordo sempre durante il periodo
all'università mia mamma mi diede un
certo punto una mano all e qui ora a
mettere su durante la tesi le le
fotografie del di una tesi di ingegneria
no lei insegnante di lettere cosa fa mi
monta tutti gli assi al contrario invece
che mettere la navigazione giusta ripete
tutti dall'altra parte ma e torniamo a
noi
allora questo è un gruppo di ragazzi di
colleghi di amici con cui noi
sviluppiamo delle idee
cosa sono le idee per noi le idee sono
queste famose scintille di cui stiamo
parlando oggi e sono delle scintille che
noi sviluppiamo e sono profondamente
motivate dal miglioramento della qualità
della vita
oggi vi presento tre idee e poi vorrei
commentare con voi qual è stato il
processo creativo di queste idee
la prima riguarda un soggetto che ha
avuto un ictus all'età di 50 anni e
rimane con un arto par etico cioè la sua
mano non è più in grado di stringere
nessun oggetto quindi non può fa non può
fare nessun compito di tipo b manuale
sostanzialmente non può più aprire una
bottiglia non può più utilizzare il
dentifricio lavarsi i denti la mattina
perché ha bisogno di entrambe le mani e
che è chiaramente nell'ambito della
robotica non sa o non ho trovato alcun
tipo di soluzione che fosse utile per
questo tipo di soggetti perché loro
hanno ancora l'arto presente ma non
funziona guardando le mani di mia figlia
che anche lei qui commessa sera insieme
a stefania guardando le mani mia figlia
mi rendo conto che in realtà per
afferrare un oggetto c'è bisogno
solamente di un palmo e di un dito ok e
quindi cosa potevo fare per lord
noi abbiamo cercato di aiutare queste
persone che hanno un ictus e non possono
più muovere una mano semplicemente
aggiungendo un dito robotico in più
vedete qui in questo particolare caso è
uno sviluppo non so se c'è l'audio è uno
sviluppo che è un titolo gotico
sostanzialmente che riesce in qualche
modo a unirsi insieme alla mano del
soggetto che è rimasta pareti camauro
svolge la funzione del palmo residuale e
lui realizza una presa ibrida tra il
dito robotico e la mano del del soggetto
vedete che questo tipo di tecnologia è
una tecnologia molto semplice
sostanzialmente un pollice in più ma è
una tecnologia dirompente
guardate in questo caso questo soggetto
io lo avevo appena incontrato due minuti
prima di entrare in questa stanza
lui ha montato il senso di uso robotico
e riesce a afferrare una bottiglia e
portarla alla bocca e bere cosa che non
riusciva a fare prima
a causa di questo problema di motilità
di mobilità delle sue mani lo stesso
soggetto guardate riesce tranquillamente
a tranquillamente no perché in realtà ha
delle difficoltà a utilizzare il senso
di robotico per stabilizzare la
bottiglia mentre con l'altra mano lui
riesce in qualche modo a rimettere
questo tappo sulla bottiglia e questo
guardate per delle persone che devono
essere riabilitata in qualche modo è
tutto beneficio perché grazie a questo
tipo di tecnologie riescono a rimettere
in movimento le loro e loro i loro art
qui vediamo in questo in questo video
vediamo alessandro che sta utilizzando
il sesto di robotico sulla sua barca e
qui sta raccontando la sua storia e dice
che ha avuto un
ictus quando aveva 50 anni e ha sofferto
per molto tempo e poi a un certo punto
ho avuto un atto di speranza quando ha
incontrato noi che abbiamo proposto a
lui l'utilizzo di questo sesto dito
robotico che gli ha permesso di
rigovernare la sua barca a vela per lui
era impossibile la sbarca venera la sua
vita
cioè lui era sempre sulla barca a vela
grazie a questo tipo di tecnologia lui
riesce a rimanere tutti gli strumenti
presenti nel nella barca a vela e qui io
racconto questo tipo di tecnologie
questo tipo di tecnologie sono molto
semplici perché c'è un motore dei
tendini
un sistema che si adatta a qualsiasi
forma di oggetto e qui vediamo
alessandro che si muove con con questa
con questo tipo di dissesto sito
robotico bene andiamo a un altro ha
un'altra idea
un'altra idea che abbiamo sviluppato nei
lobi nel laboratorio è un'idea che cerca
di aiutare le persone non vedenti
le persone non vedenti hanno bisogno di
un di un volontario cioè di un soggetto
che lo aiuto a muoversi da un punto un
altro se un non vedente dovesse
raggiungere questo teatro e non è di qui
ma anche se fossi di qui avrebbe bisogno
comunque di un volontario che lo porta
da una parte all'altra
guardate il volontario ora in questo
caso sta utilizzando il tatto per
comunicare con il non vedente infatti è
sotto bracciano e quindi sta dicendo
viene a destra viene a sinistra questo
perché non glielo non vuole utilizzare
la voce per comunicare con lui perché
perché i non vedenti sostanzialmente
utilizzano l'udito per ascoltare per
vedere tutto quello che c'è intorno alla
città e quindi qualunque cosa che gli
mascheri questa percezione è
assolutamente negativa per loro e quindi
utilizzano il tatto
ovviamente non possono utilizzare la
pista in questo caso noi abbiamo pensato
di dare una mano al al non vedente
aiutando il volontario perché il
volontario per per per andare a
supportare il non vedente deve prendere
la macchina arrivare il dove c'è da
aiutare il non vedente parcheggiare e
poi finalmente aiutarti abbiamo cercato
di aiutare il non vedente cercando di
tenere
il volontario a casa semplicemente
facendo questo tipo di tecnologia
guardate qui ci sono due braccialetti
che sostituiscono le mani del volontario
in questo caso il non vedente a una
telecamera che trasmette in streaming il
segnale sullo schermo
e qui c'è il volontario che manda dei
segnali a destra e sinistra e questi
segnali arrivano a destra e sinistra su
quelle bande che c'ha rose gialle li
danno delle indicazioni di di direzione
ancora un'altra idea le stessa
tecnologia però questa volta utilizzata
non come braccialetti ma come cavigliere
queste cavigliere sostanzialmente danno
un ritmo ok
immaginate un ritmo di tipo tattile no
quindi un ritmo di questo tipo è il
soggetto che sente questo ritmo tende ad
allineare la sua camminata il suo passo
a questo tipo di ritmo noi lo abbiamo
utilizzato per soggetti sani ma abbiamo
poi avuto l'idea di utilizzare queste
tecnologie anche per soggetti di tipo
parkinsoniano se vedete in questo video
il soggetto parkinsoniano ha un problema
di di marcia il suo il suo passo è molto
e molto breve è molto irregolare
qui lo vedete sulla sinistra mentre
sulla destra noi abbiamo le cavigliere
sono sono accese sulla sinistra alle
caviglie re non sono accese e si vede
come questo
queste questo tipo di tecnologie riesce
a rimettere in movimento la marcia e
quindi regolarizzare il passo del
parkinsoniano ancora un altro problema
che hanno i parkinsoniani il problema
del freezing il freezing della marcia
consiste in questo cioè una è un sintomo
di questa patologia cioè come se il
pieve rimanesse attaccato al suolo e
loro hanno l'impressione di camminare ma
in realtà non vanno avanti proprio per
questo tipo di fenomeno è molto spesso
infatti cadono con queste cavigliere
quello che succede è che il
parkinsoniano a un app una semplice app
che quando lui si rende conto che
a questo freezing della marcia e non
riesce più a camminare basta premere un
bottone di questa app si partono questi
stimoli tattili che arrivano le caviglie
re e il soggetto comincia a ri camminare
tranquillamente
guardate qui abbiamo il soggetto nel
nostro laboratorio
a questo punto il soggetto avrà un
problema di freezing vedete proprio in
questo momento le carriere sono spente
in questo momento lui rimane bloccato
non vuole bloccarsi ovviamente cosa fa
in questo caso c'è il mio amico e se
collega simone rossi che accende la up
partono questi stimoli e lui riparte ok
quindi queste tecnologie è semplicemente
dico semplicemente perché a volte le
idee e le scintille devono essere
semplici per essere efficaci e allora
queste tre idee cosa hanno in comune
queste tre idee hanno in comune una
profonda conoscenza cioè molto spesso le
scintille nascono quando si conosce
veramente fino in fondo il suo il tema
lo studio il problema che si sta si sta
affrontando a vendola vengono molto
spesso anche in contesti di
multidisciplinarietà cioè la
multidisciplinarietà esattamente dove i
confini delle singole discipline si
incontrano la medicina e l'ingegneria la
la matematica la fisica cioè proprio in
quegli intrecci che si riesce a trovare
il l'ambiente più proficuo per generare
queste scintille e ovviamente tantissimo
impegno
l'altro elemento comune a queste tre
idee e le idee che rompono gli schemi
qui guardate che ci sono degli aerei che
vanno secondo un flusso principale e poi
c'è un aereo che va in modo diverso se
voi vedete questo esattamente è uno dei
motivi fondamentali che ha mosso la
generazione delle scintille nel nostro
laboratorio pensiamo
la prima idea del sesto edito qual era
il mainstream il flusso principale il
flusso principale era lavorare su gli
amputati gli amputati non hanno un arto
faccio una protesi robotica ok gli
amputati in un anno una gamba
faccio un arto robotico che glie lo
sostituisce in questi soggetti che hanno
subito amputazioni bene purtroppo per
chi ha avuto un ictus o che ha un arto
pareti con l'arto è ancora lì non
possiamo utilizzare una protesi
dobbiamo inventarci qualcosa di diverso
e quindi abbiamo creato questo dito che
era completamente diverso dalla
tecnologia che pensava di sviluppare
queste queste protesi così come l'idea
dei non vedenti
questa è stata anche una cosa
completamente dirompente perché tutti si
sono concentrati nell'aiutare il non
vedente mettendo delle cinture
tecnologiche delle telecamere dei radar
in realtà anche in questo caso noi
abbiamo avuto un pensiero completamente
diverso
siamo andati in una direzione
completamente probabilmente ortogonale a
quella principale e abbiamo detto no noi
vogliamo aiutare il volontario e non il
non vedente e aiutando il volontario
paradossalmente siamo stati molto
d'aiuto anche i non vedenti perché
tenendo il volontario a casa io non
vedente a foggia
posso farmi aiutare anche da un
volontario a milano a new york
quindi il volontariato viene in qualche
modo liberato dai vincoli geografici di
tenere il soggetto non vedente e il
volontario nella stessa nella stessa
città un altro elemento fondamentale di
queste idee
e la core ha il coraggio il coraggio di
pensare e di comunicare idee bizzarre
sapete com'è andato il sesto dito che
sta avendo un grande successo per queste
persone con con arto pareti co il sesto
dito è nato semplicemente dal dada da
un'idea bizzarra che abbiamo avuto nel
nostro laboratorio quando un certo punto
guardando la mia mano ho guardato ho
visto che c'era una notevole asimmetria
la notevole asimmetria è legata al fatto
che abbiamo un unico pollice non ne
abbiamo due
e allora abbiamo cominciato ad elaborare
il l'idea di sviluppare un un pollice in
più che poi si è rilevato assolutamente
essenziale nello sviluppo del sesto dito
robotico per i soggetti con l'arto
pareti co
se in quel caso io o qualunque altro del
mio laboratorio non avesse avuto il
coraggio di raccontare in consensi dove
si parla e si fa brainstorming questa
idea bizzarra questa cosa sarebbe
rimasta all'interno di qualche meandro
del nostro cervello senza poter poi
rendersi utile per per la comunità così
come nell'ambito dei non vedenti dei
volontari
molto spesso si pensa cioè cosa fai
cerchi di aiutare il volontario invece
di aiutare di aiutare il non vedente è
un'idea bizzarra un'idea strana dobbiamo
tutti aiutare la persona non vedente
invece avendo il coraggio di raccontare
questa cosa ci aiutiamo invece il
volontario che deve fare cinque ore di
impegno per un'ora di di volontariato e
quindi tirando fuori questa idea
bizzarra siamo riusciti ad avere grande
grandi risultati che sono quelli che vi
ho presentato un altro elemento
fondamentale per la gente per la
generazione delle scintille e l'amicizia
guardate quando nascono delle idee ci
sono dei professionisti ci sono degli
esperti ci sono gli scienziati dei
ricercatori dei tecnologi ma se non si
innesta un livello emotivo che fa
parlare queste persone a un livello più
profondo della sola comunicazione
scientifica non si riescono a generare
quelle scintille che poi sono quelle
cose che possiamo utilizzare per
migliorare per migliorare la qualità
della vita e questo è quello che succede
con alessandro che è diventato un amico
dal soggetto che era con cui lavoravamo
simone rossi con cui collaboriamo e i
ragazzi del mio laboratorio con cui
abbiamo un
diciamo una frequenza così quotidiana
che sono avere ampliamenti diventati una
una nuova famiglia una famiglia che
frequentiamo tutti i giorni
bene voglio parlare del futuro e per
parlare del futuro nelle idee risposto a
un mondo più tecnologico e voglio fare
con voi questa riflessione oggi le auto
che noi abbiamo che compriamo le auto i
telefonini hanno mediamente le stesse
qualità produttive ok infatti mediamente
costano più o meno la stessa cifra
questo perché questo perché le linee di
produzione la grande automazione la
grande come dire organizzazione ha fatto
sì che
la produzione di questi oggetti è
diventata uno standard cioè io
produttore di auto posso andare in cina
compro il mio sistema di produzione
della realizzo cioè non c'è più la
differenza che c'è la prima tra un'auto
tedesca è un'auto asiatica dove c'erano
tutti gli operai che lavoravano
sull'auto perché semplicemente compro le
macchine le macchine costruiscono con la
stessa qualità sia in cina che in europa
bene allora se la differenza non è più
nel come si fanno le cose dove sarà la
vera differenza tra le varie tra le
varie aziende o tre le varie attività
produttive la differenza sarà solamente
nel cosa facciamo
non nel come lo facciamo e il cosa
facciamo nasce solo ed esclusivamente
dalla generazione delle idee dallo
sviluppo delle idee dalle scintille che
riusciamo a generare nei nostri
laboratori e negli ambienti che che
frequentiamo finisco con una foto o
ancora del mio team che vorrei
ringraziare sempre per quello che mi
consentono di fare tutti i giorni e di
essere anche qui oggi con voi
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]